hey everyone welcome to this live
session by simply learn
our topic for today is cyber security
training for beginners
here we will acquaint you with various
cyber security concepts
and help you learn cyber security from
scratch
let's wait for a bit as people join in
before we proceed make sure to hit the
subscribe button and the bell icon to
never miss an update from simply learn
now let's jump in and see what's in
store for us
we have an interesting lineup for this
session
firstly we look at the rise of
cybercrimes with the help of real world
cyberattacks
then we will move on to understanding
the various types of cyber attacks we
can fall prey to
following which we will preview with the
importance of cybersecurity
after that we will understand various
networking terminologies as
networking is the foundation of
cybersecurity
our next topic will acquaint you with
cybersecurity goals and finally we will
have a look at how you can tackle
cybercrimes
so without further ado let's begin with
the rise of cyber crimes
so let's talk about the wannacry cyber
attack this is something that happened
way back in 2017.
this attack took the world by storm it
encrypted the data of organizations and
hackers demanded ransom from those
organizations to decrypt their own data
so what exactly happened well this
attack originated in may 2017 in asia
and then spread across the world
and how did this happen well there was a
vulnerability that was identified in
microsoft windows
the smb vulnerability smba which is
server message block is essentially the
file sharing and the printer sharing
services
that you use in a lan environment on
windows operating system
by default these are enabled on your
desktop and there is a hardening guide
that people utilize to either upgrade
the version of smb
to more secure version or disable smb
and utilize something else
now this was an unknown vulnerability
and this was targeted and within days
more than 230 000 computers were
infected across 150 countries
so the victims were the users who used
the unsupported version of microsoft
windows and those users who hadn't
installed the new microsoft security
update of april 2017.
now when we say this was unidentified
microsoft knew of this vulnerability and
in fact they had released a patch in
april
of 2017 to mitigate this vulnerability
within two months of that release this
attack had happened
now in a real world scenario it is not
possible for all the servers and devices
to be upgraded
to the latest patch level because
organizations need
to test those patches to see if those
patches are going to interfere with the
services that they are providing
and hence no organization will
completely patch up at any point in time
and this was the flaw that sadly took
down a lot of organizations
the patch was available but some were
not utilizing it yet
and they did not see it as a high value
risk and suddenly something happened and
a wannacry took place now
so what happened was a crypto worm
called wannacry
which basically encrypts the data and
locks the user out of their own
computers
and they get the screen in front of them
which says your data has been encrypted
and it gives them a link and they are
demanded to pay 300 to 600 dollars to
the hackers to retrieve the decryption
key for their data
now here obviously you're not going to
pay cash to a hackers neither are you
going to make a bank transfer
because both of the ways you can
identify the hackers and then track them
down
so the hackers demanded this exchange
via bitcoin's cryptocurrency
this is the best way to remain anonymous
and the best way to make payments over
the internet without being identified
so what was the impact of this attack
around 200
000 to 300 000 computers were infected
it sounds like a small number of
computers when you're talking about the
global volume
however the services that it affected
were very huge in uk it was the national
health service
and the frequencies of the patients were
postponed here
fedex renault nissan all of these
organizations got compromised
and the production lines basically shut
down for a few days
till the data retrieved from backup was
restored
and then they try to bring back
everything to normal
this shows what a huge impact the
wannacry attack had on the world
next let us have a look at the attack
faced by dunkin donuts
in february 2019 dunkin donuts announced
that the users of its rewards programs
were targeted by a credential stuffing
attack
that means that the attacker stole the
credentials usernames and passwords of
customers of dunkin donuts
now we think dunkin donuts they sell
donuts how much could it impact anyone
but if you have an online account with
dunkin donuts
you also have a personal identifiable
information stored in those accounts
for example your name address credit
card information
maybe your social security number or
your national insurance card or
something like that
which can lead to identity theft people
can misuse that information pretend to
be you
and then take out loans or do
transactions in your name
where you're going to end up paying
those bills so stealing of such kind of
data is going to impact
all the users adversely here the first
name
last name and email ids were stolen this
is still good enough to launch
social engineering attacks and target
these victims through phishing attacks
or similar attacks
now that we saw a few real world
examples of cyber attacks
let's now look into the different types
of cyber attacks
so we are going to discuss these six
types of attacks they are malware
social engineering attacks man in the
middle attack denial of service
sql injections and password attacks if
you look at this
malware's basically target host
operating systems
social engineering attacks would address
or attack the gullibility of a human
being with the help of a computer
for example sending a fake mail or
hosting a fake website
man in the middle attack would target a
network and then try to capture data
packets within a network
thus compromising your credentials a
denial of service attack would crash a
service
sql injection attacks would attack an
application and a password attack would
attack the user
and passwords of accounts thus taking
advantage of weak passwords and getting
access to your accounts
so let's start with malware malware
basically refers to malicious software
the first part of malicious mull and the
wear out of software becomes malware
malwares are nothing but vehicles in
which hackers embed payloads
payloads could be viruses worms
ransomware trojans
so they hide these kind of malicious
software within the legitimate looking
softwares
and post them on the internet people who
are interested in those kind of software
will obviously download them and since
they are looking very legitimate they
will try to install them
thus accidentally and unknowingly
installing a trojan virus
or a ransomware on their machine now
most of us have done this at one point
in time
where we have looked at pirated software
because we did not want to pay for it
and then we probably go to torrance and
then search for those softwares download
them
and there's a keygen.exe over there
which we have to execute
and then we have to copy that code the
exe file
that comes out or the keygen that you
have to replace it and it's a very
convoluted process but the fact that you
have to restore some code with some
other code
would basically mean that there is
something wrong with that file
so 99 of the time these programs would
have viruses or trojans emitted within
them
and it is going to affect the security
posture of your computers
if you scan akigen.exes with any
antivirus
across the globe they will always report
them as malware
and they will probably want to delete
those kind of files
so how do the user machines get infected
it gets infected into a system when a
user clicks on suspicious links
now obviously if you think it is a
suspicious link you're not going to
click on it
but you trust the link or you're
compelled to click on it just out of
curiosity
let's say you click on that link there's
a redirect term
it downloads an attachment from a
malicious server and it gets installed
on your machine
most of the common ways a virus or a
worm is spread is through usb devices
people pass around
and you have no idea where the device
has been used before
and you plug it into your machine and if
there is a virus on that usb
device it will get infected on your
machine as well
then let's talk about social engineering
attack
now this is where your people skills
come into the picture
this is the art of manipulating people
and convincing them to give up
confidential information
either knowingly or unknowingly so most
likely well we trust our friends right
and we talk to them a lot and we give
out some confidential information
which we would not give out to others
what if somebody is pretending to be our
friend and just to get this information
out of us
and we trust this person we give out
that information
and we certainly get affected because of
it that i'm not saying that everybody in
the world does that
but it is one of the most common attacks
that is experienced in the computing
world
now social engineering attacks can be
broken down into three categories
here we have phishing attack spear
phishing attack and whaling attack
first is a phishing attack where you're
targeting a user by sending out
fake mails or fake websites and their
gullibility into clicking on those links
and then giving out information
basically it is a practice wherein a
hacker usually sends fake mails
which look really genuine on hosts fake
websites which also look genuine
and looks like they're from a trusted
source once you click on those links
there would be embedded scripts or
embedded malware which would then be
executed and then get installed on your
machines
compromising the security of your device
these utilities could be used to steal
your credit card information
steal data from your computer upload
data to your computer
use your computer as a bot and anything
and everything that the hacker might
want to do
spearfishing is a variation of fishing
now phishing is a non-targeted attack
it is to the whole world at large
whoever becomes a victim
however sphere phishing is targeted
attack
it is to a specific individual or a
group of individuals in an organization
so it becomes a customized attack you
identify the victim you identify the
flaws that are existing in the
organization
you identify the gullibility of the
victim create that fake mail to suit
that particular situation
send it across to them they'll then
click on that link and get infected by
whatever payloads that you have embedded
with it
meanwhile wailing is when you are
targeting particularly wealthy or
powerful people in the industry
so normally when you're targeting the
ceo cfos high level management people of
an organization
it would be known as wheeling attack
then we come to the network attacks man
in the middle
this is also known as an eavesdropping
attack which literally means that you're
going to listen in on to somebody's
conversation
for example in the figure the client is
trying to talk to the server
but you become a man in the middle and
you try to listen and on to the
conversation
this is going on now obviously the
conversation over here may not be audio
but with data that is being exchanged
between the server
and the client you just listen in and
you make a copy of that data
you store it at your end the data could
contain user names passwords
it may also contain confidential
information and help you compromise data
the attacking computer takes the ip
address of the client the client is not
aware of this
how about this that the client is trying
to communicate with the server
you spoof yourself as a default gateway
or as a trusted device
and the client thinks that this is
through you that they need to
communicate to the server
and thus they start sending data via
your pc
so this attack normally happens on
public wi-fi networks
thus it is recommended that you don't
use public wi-fi's
for example you go to a coffee shop they
have free wi-fi there and you connect to
it
start surfing you start browsing you're
always signed into google facebook
accounts
your bank accounts and whatnot and then
there's a sniffer there is a hacker
who's doing a man-in-the-middle attack
capturing all that data now it's not an
easy attack but it can be done
so this diagram shows where the man in
the middle attack has become successful
and now that the client and the server
both are sending information
without knowing that the attacker is
capturing all the data
then comes the denial of service attack
the motive in a dos attack
is not to benefit monetarily but to
bring down a service for legitimate
users
that is just causing harm to the
organization
for example if i consume the bandwidth
off to a particular website since there
is no more bandwidth left
other legitimate users who want to
interact with website will not be able
to connect to the website
thus creating a denial of service to
those legitimate users
now it may not be possible for me to use
my laptop to target a cluster of servers
because obviously the bandwidth at the
other end would be very high
so i would distribute my attack across
multiple devices
thus creating a distributed denial of
service called a ddos attack
then we come to the sql injection
sql stands for structured query language
which is the language that is used by
applications to interact with websites
so let it be a microsoft sql database
mysql database oracle sql
the syntax may be a little bit different
but it is still the structured query
language
that applications utilize to interact
with database
now the queries that are created by the
applications need to be checked at the
application level itself
so developers need to be very careful of
how they are going to create those
queries what queries are allowed to go
to the database
because the database is designed to
answer queries it doesn't know what is a
legitimate query
if it receives a query it is going to
try to execute it and give out
information
thus a hacker may insert a malicious
query
or malicious queries into a sql server
through the vulnerable application
causing a security event so depending on
the queries that have been created
the attacker could delete some data or
modify
add edit data or do anything that would
compromise the integrity
and the security of the database
for example the dunkin donuts attack
apart from being a credential stuffing
attack
since they got access to the database
they could have added or deleted any
information about
any users that were there
then we come to the most common attacks
password attack
this is the easiest way to hack into a
system by cracking a password of a user
this is done in multiple ways so there
would be a brute force attack where you
try
every combination out of the alphabet or
the character set that is allowed to be
utilized to create
passwords for example we have password
policies right
alphabet and uppercase and lowercase a
through z
capitals and in lowercase 0 through 9
for numerical values and alphanumeric
characters or special characters like
exclamation marks percentile
ampersands etc so we are normally
encouraged to create a randomized
password with
all of these in a randomized manner it
should not be based on a dictionary word
it should not be our names or our phone
numbers or phone numbers in reverse
so why are these policies created
these policies are essentially created
to create a password that is difficult
to crack
even by a brute force attack so if
you've got a lengthy password which is
very randomized with numeric
alphanumeric special characters
and whatnot it would be very difficult
and the compute level that it may
consume may make this
attacker redundant for example a 16
character password which is hashed using
sha-256 would take around single pc
now imagine the amount of time it takes
it is 100 successful attack but the time
it takes may make it redundant
meanwhile a dictionary attack is where
you're creating a file which will have a
list of all the common passwords
that are utilized by users so instead of
the permutations and combinations of all
the alphabets or all the characters
you're just creating a list of all the
probable passwords that may be utilized
and then you're comparing those
passwords to see if those passwords
match
so these kinds of attacks are effective
against users who use
very commonly used passwords dictionary
based words as their passwords
now let's talk about the types of
network attacks
an active attack an attack when the
intruder attempts to disrupt a network's
normalcy
and modifies the data and alters the
data at the same time
so as we can see in the diagram there's
a sender and there's a receiver
attacker is the man in the middle who is
trying to create the active attack
so when the sender sends the data to the
receiver the attacker intercepts that
data
modifies the data and then sends it back
to the receiver since the attacker is a
man in the middle as we have seen in the
previous attacks
neither the receiver nor the sender
would be aware of the attacker
and thus they would not be aware of the
modification that has been done
meanwhile in a passive attack the
intruder just eavesdrops on the data
they just listen and on to the
conversation but they do not modify the
data at any time
so they just capture the packets they
copy the contents
so that they can use that at a later
stage
so we have seen all of these attacks so
far but what is the motivation behind
them
why would anyone want to create these
attacks and for what particular reason
so let's talk about the reasons for
cyber attacks
now let's start off with cyber terrorism
it is an attack carried out by a group
of terrorists against
nations to fulfill their agendas they
attack crucial infrastructure
often information of a company would be
compromised thus crippling their
infrastructure
and then the terrorists would take
advantage and demand ransom or whatever
their causes
next a cyber warfare nations hack into
another nation's network to cause
damage by doing so critical data is
stolen and infrastructure can also be
hampered
now this is where espionage happens
countries are known to spy on each other
especially their enemies and enemy at
any point in time would want to know
what the other nations are doing
so earlier on we should look at spy
movies where we used to plant spice and
send spice across the borders
across the lands and try to spy on them
now we can do that sitting at home or
rather we can do that through our
computers
and this is exactly what cyber warfare
is
cyber espionage this is a technology
which is used to gain information
without the consent from its owner now
this can be in a political situation
or in a corporate situation where a
computer is trying to spy on their
other vendors and trying to figure out
how their business models are more
successful
or what their business strategies are so
that these guys can keep a step
or two ahead of their competitors
and finally the most common of all
personal differences
somebody hates somebody and they want to
take revenge and that is why cyber
attacks can take place as well
so this is why we want cyber security
cyber security should be in place to
prevent these kinds of attacks
so what exactly cyber security it refers
to the practice of protecting networks
programs computer systems and their
components from unauthorized digital
access and attacks
so whatever your digital footprint could
it be servers computers switches routers
web servers web applications that you're
hosting
or services that you're consuming from
the cloud or providing to other
customers
you need to secure all of these to
ensure that the integrity
and the confidentiality of these
services is intact
and none of these services are affected
by any cyber attacks which could lead to
disastrous results
so the main difference we want to
understand here is the difference
between cyber security and information
security
well information security is data within
the organization
where they handle sensitive information
or proprietary information
copyrighted or printed information and
they want to secure it from data leaks
cyber security is basically a technique
used to protect the integrity of a
network
so this is when you're going to go on
the web and on the internet
you're going to secure your devices that
you have deployed allowing people to
access your infrastructure from the
outside
so what could be the cost of not being
cyber secure
if you get hacked or if your data is
compromised or if
information is compromised you could
have a lot of repercussions
your goodwill will go for a toss you may
be open for lawsuits
not only from clients but from customers
as well you could be open for fines or
penalties from government organizations
for failing to follow the law of the
land
customer trust will obviously be
hampered if you have been hacked
and your data has been compromised you
wouldn't want to deal with that
organization in the future
all of this could land the organization
in a financial crisis
where all the lawsuits and penalties
that are being imposed could basically
bankrupt that organization and thus take
it out of circulation
so now let's look at some basic network
terminologies which we need to
understand to go further into the cyber
security world
first and foremost network what is a
network
it is nothing but a group of
interconnected devices
it could be servers could be
workstations could be laptops could be
any device
file printers and whatnot to be
interconnected with each other as you
can see in the diagram it is used for
communication
it's primarily used for data
transmissions and to communicate between
various terminals
it is also used to share data
information it could be wired or
wireless so you've got a wired line or
at home we all have wireless networks
where we connect all our devices we use
them for streaming videos we use them to
connect to the internet
a network is nothing but a collection of
interconnected devices that are allowed
to communicate with each other freely so
that the business can be continued in a
proper manner
next we have server server is nothing
but a hardware device that is supposed
to handle requests of data
information allow network services to
function from other computers and
devices
so this is where we built a client
server relationship
where on the server we have got the
major software we got the data that is
stored over there and clients and
interact with the server to consume
that data in a particular manner that
would help them make sense and analyze
that data and generate business out of
them
then internet internet is nothing but
the collection of multiple networks
globally
so all the networks that we have across
the globe when they are interconnected
with each other
that is what internet is and if you just
go back and talk about servers this is
what allows the internet to be formed
so every organizations when they publish
their servers on the internet
and they allow everyone to interconnect
through these servers
so that is where the internet comes in
be the servers being the backbone of the
internet
obviously for the servers to communicate
with each others we will need switches
routers and other devices for data
transmissions to happen
so these are the multiple networks that
could be individual networks
interconnected together to form the
internet across the globe
next we have tcpip for the internet to
work there would be a set of protocols
for transmissions to be allowed across
the globe
now this is where tcpip or the
transmission control protocol over
internet protocol comes into the picture
so if you remember we use communication
channels like tcp
or the transmission control protocol and
udp user data grant protocol
when we connect web servers we talked
about the http protocol
and if you want to secure then we'll
talk about the imap
pop3 and all of these protocols now
where do these protocols come from
it is nothing but a suit of the tcp ib
software
which contains all of these protocols
which allow computers to communicate
with each other
if tcp wouldn't have been there our
network would have collapsed
now when we have the tcp and we want to
communicate across the globe how do we
identify devices on the internet
because the devices don't know us they
are not going to use our usernames and
passwords to communicate with each other
but when i want to connect to a website
or a device
how do i identify it on the intranet or
the internet
i obviously use ip address now ip
addresses are nothing but the internet
protocol addresses
as shown on your screen here's an
example now there's a lot of
classification of ip addresses and some
of these ip addresses work on the
internet
some of them are supposed to work on
private lands next we have mac addresses
the second way that we are identified on
the internet or the
intranet are with mac addresses so media
access controls
or mac addresses are hard-coded
addresses
given to our network interface cards
these cannot be modified physically
at any point in time however there are
techniques to spoof mac addresses which
we can then obfuscate
our existing address and give us a new
one next we have router
we have been talking about routers and
switches router is nothing but a device
that passes packets back and forth
across
the networks it draws the data in the
appropriate path
so it is an intelligent device it can
understand ib addresses and mac
addresses
it can identify different parts of
reaching a particular network
for example if i'm sitting in india and
i want to communicate across the world
to america
it is the routers that would map this
park store it and their cache
so when i tried to connect to that
server they would retrieve it from the
cache and send the packet across the
globe
so the home router as we use at home on
wi-fi is our default gateway to connect
to the internet
thus it allows our internal devices to
communicate with each other using
internal ip addresses
and then when we want to connect to the
internet after routing
it will send the packet to other servers
that we want to communicate with
next up we have domain now what is a
domain
a domain is referred to as a group of
computers and other devices that are
interconnected and treated as a whole
now a domain is used by an organization
so let's say if i'm xyz
being the name of the organization and i
want to create a domain which would
allow me to create a group of
interconnected computers for my
employees to interconnect with each
other
and send and manage data i'm going to
create
a domain for my organization and attach
all the devices
create users and interconnect them using
a domain so that is why
you are going to have a centralized
approach of a server client relationship
where you are going to have a main
domain and you're going to have devices
connected to the domain
now when we go on to the internet the
domain name is nothing but the base part
of our website
so when you say google.com and you type
it in your browser you're taken to the
webpage called google.com
which is the search engine that you're
connected
but for google the organization at the
other end they would have a data center
over there
which would have all the relevant data
which allows you to search throughout
the information so for them
the domain would be a data center where
all that information is stored
but for us consumers a website called
google.com would be a domain for us to
visit
that particular website and consume the
services that they are offering on the
internet
so here's the example it is https
which means that it is secure website
port 443 and we're connecting to
cybersecurity.com
cybersecurity.com becomes a domain name
https becomes a protocol that we want to
utilize to connect with that particular
website
next we have dns or the domain name
system
it is nothing but an index something
like a phone book which is responsible
for mapping the domain name into its
corresponding ip address
now remember as mentioned earlier there
are only two ways of being identified on
the internet either the mac address or
the ip address
if it is devices if it is computers it
would obviously be ip addresses
but if i type in google.com i'm giving
it a domain name
so there is a dns server which is an
index or works like an index or moreover
a phone book which will have a list of
all the domains with the corresponding
ip addresses
so whenever i type in google.com the
request goes to a dns server
the dns server is queried the ip address
of google.com is identified
pasted it onto the packet and then the
packet is routed through the router to
the path that it has in mind to reach
google.com server
here you can replace google.com with
cybersecurity.com
as seen on the screen the local pc
queries a dns server the dns server
replies back with ip address
now if you're wondering how does this
work if we take an example of home
network
the isp gives us default gateway or a
router within their ip address
for dns servers and default gateways so
when we try to connect to the router
the router has the ip and dns server
and it routes that query to the dns
server
the dns server replies back with
appropriate ip address
the router then takes the ip address
figures out the path and sends it across
the targeted server next up we have dhcp
or the dynamic host configuration
protocol
it is a protocol that dynamically
assigns ip addresses to the devices in
the network
so we have discussed that ib addresses
are required by computers to communicate
with each other
but who associates or who gives these ip
addresses to these computers
so for that to happen we have got a dhcp
server
that is created if you take your home
networks it is a router that has the
dhcp rule installed on it
so whenever machine boots up it sends
out a broadcast request looking for the
dhcp server
and then there is a communication with
the dhcp server
the dhcp server then allocates an ip
address to the computer who's requesting
it
and once the ip addresses are located on
the entries within the dhcp servers
cache
or with the corresponding mac address of
that particular machine
moving on we have vpn
the next topic called vpn or a virtual
private network
it is a connection between a vpn server
and a vpn client
it's basically an encrypted channel that
you're creating between two endpoints
and the main reason for a vpn is to
encrypt your data
so that it is now no longer subject to
man in the middle
or each dropping or modification attacks
so this is a layer of security that
you're adding when you are connecting to
the internet
using an encrypted channel which would
prevent you from getting hacked
or your data being compromised by
hackers
so as you can see here and if you
remember the previous talks that we have
seen
the hacker was able to copy the data
very easily now that it is an encrypted
channel
even if the hacker tries to eavesdrop
and capture the data it will format it
in such a way that they would not be
able to make sense out of it
now the attacker or the hacker will have
to try to decrypt the data
so that's another attack that they would
have to execute to find out the
encryption key
decrypt the data and then look at what
the data was
now let's understand what bots are
before moving to botnet
bots are nothing but the softwares that
can be installed on vulnerable machines
that would allow the hacker
to send commands to infect machines to
generate some traffic
or to do what the command tells him to
do most of the botnets are used for
distributed denial of service attack
if you remember the dos and the ddos
that we discussed a while back
this is where we tie up with how they
are executed
so a bot master or a hacker would try to
identify vulnerable devices
across the internet and try to install
the bot onto those devices
the bot is essentially a software that
would revert back to the bot master and
advertise their availability whenever
they have been powered on
a collection of such infested devices
would essentially be called a bot
net when there are enough number of
machines that the attacker feels
good enough to launch the attack on
targeted servers
the hacker will then initiate those
devices send commands to the botmaster
to the bots and the bots would then
generate that kind of traffic
but whatever they have been configured
for and then attack the targeted server
now this is also done to optimize the
identity of the hackers since the attack
is being generated through the botnet
the ip addresses of the botnet computers
would be reported to the target
so not the actual hacker's ip address
so it would be very difficult to find
out who the hacker was and this also
depends on the size of the botnet
so this you can see is the attack that
has been created over the victims and
the malicious traffic has been generated
through the botnet
and the victims have been targeted
through that so as mentioned once the
attack has been done
when it comes to forensically
investigating at the victim's end they
would find the ip addresses of the
botnet and not
the attacker now let's start talking
about network security controls
network security controls are nothing
but implementations of various devices
to enhance the security of a particular
network
these could be firewalls intrusion
detection systems or intrusion
prevention systems honeypots
let's look at a review of what these
devices are now a firewall can be a
hardware or a software that is
responsible for allowing
or disallowing a certain amount of
traffic to
or from your computer so these are
basically created to enhance the
security
posture of your network where you can
configure for certain level of traffic
to be allowed and disallowed
now a firewall is not going to decide by
itself what is a good amount of traffic
or what is bad traffic
you are going to configure the firewall
by creating rules based on the ip
address
port numbers protocols based on this the
firewall will then analyze if the
incoming traffic
is good or not and if it should be
allowed or not
in case of explicit rules which says
deny the traffic it will drop the
packets or it will delete the packets
it will not allow the packets to go past
so if it is good traffic that means it
reaches a rule that has been created
that allows the traffic to go through
the firewall and it will allow it
if it's bad traffic that means there is
a rule which denies that traffic to pass
through
it will get blocked at the firewall
level itself and it will not enter the
network
similarly an intrusion detection system
ids
it is designed to detect unauthorized
taxes to systems or intrusion attempts
as well
now it works along with a firewall now
the main thing here is that there's a
database
against which it can compare the traffic
so most of the attacks that we have
talked
about there are some distinct signatures
that would cause concern
or that would highlight that kind of an
attack most of the organizations try to
develop these kind of signatures they
have them in the database
and store them on ideas so that ideas
can analyze the incoming traffic
look at patterns from the traffic coming
in or going out and compare it to the
database
of the signatures that it has and if it
matches any of the signatures
it will then detect that as an attack
and then send an alert to the
administrator
the administrator will then have to
manually come in and check it out
and an intrusion prevention system can
be configured to react to that
particular event
so if it detects something that can be
classified as an intrusion
an administrator can pre-configure it to
react to that particular packet in a
particular manner
for example drop the packets or reflect
them to a honeypot
or the administrator or do all of these
things at the same time
so as you can see on your screens
there's a hacker a set of data packets
come in and the firewall is not able to
analyze the traffic because a firewall
cannot analyze
the contents of a packet it can only
look at the ip addressing
and the ports that have been created or
the rules on which those things have
been mentioned
and then it allows the data to go
through it reaches the ids then looks at
two ways to scan
one is a signature that we have just
spoken about where the developer of the
ids creates those signatures
and stores them on to the database or
another thing that is known as heuristic
scanning
which is nothing but behavioral scanning
so it looks at the behavior of the data
and if the behavior looks malicious it
will then raise an alert and warn the
administrator
then let's come to honeypots we just
discussed in the previous slide that an
ips or an intrusion prevention system
can
be pre-configured that is if it detects
an intrusion
it may redirect a traffic to a honeypot
so what is a honeypot
a honeypot is a decoy system it is
created to showcase a certain set of
vulnerabilities to try to attract the
attention of an attacker
it's more to deceive the attacker for
example if the attacker has been able to
bypass your firewall
and your ids and now when they can scan
the entire subnet
they would come across a device which is
pretty vulnerable or showcases some
vulnerabilities which would definitely
impress the hacker
because they would think that it is a
vulnerable server which contains some
valuable data and that is exactly what
honeypot
is it's a decoy server trying to act as
a production server
trying to showcase that it has some
valuable data but also has some
vulnerabilities in it
so that the attacker can be attracted
towards it and spend some time trying to
attack it
or analyze the honeypot at the same time
the honeypot will analyze the data
traffic
and it will warn the administrator for
possible intrusion which will give the
administrator
enough time to secure the rest of the
network and they can also analyze the
logs of the honeypot
trying to understand what kind of
attacks that hacker is trying to create
and try to reverse engineer and identify
the attacker at the same time
moving on let's now talk about
cybersecurity goals that is cia
and we are not talking about the central
intelligence agency here we're talking
about the cia triad
which is confidentiality integrity and
availability
this becomes the baseline for every
security professional
at any point in time it is a cia that we
are trying to implement in an
organization to ensure that our
information security is at a very
acceptable level
now what is confidentiality integrity
and availability
confidentiality is the aspect where we
can manipulate the data or we can
configure a data to be accessible only
to authorized people
now when we say authorized you're
basically creating rules and
responsibilities where i have to
authorize some people to get access
and not authorize some people to get
access to a certain amount of data
for example if you have stored some data
on a central store
like let's say everybody has a dropbox
or onedrive right
and how do you protect your dropbox or
onedrive you have a username
and password you may enhance it using a
one-time password
or multi-factor authentication to access
the onedrive
this is where the confidentiality comes
in where you're going to protect the
data
in such a way that it cannot be accessed
by unauthorized users
so the first thing that you want to look
at is how do you manage
authorization the second aspect is
integrity
that is the trustworthiness of that data
now if you're talking about the data
that is stored on your onedrive
we would want to keep it confidential by
giving it an authentication mechanism
here you have to identify by using your
username and password
then an otp is either emailed or sent to
your mobile phone
you type in the otp to access that data
now when you're accessing that data
how can you be sure that the data has
not been modified by a hacker
somebody may have gotten their hands on
your password they would have logged in
and accessed that data
they modified it and that data is no
longer trustworthy
so how do you maintain the integrity and
trustworthiness of that data
so here we use hashing algorithms where
we take hash values of certain files
and ensure that the integrity of that
data is assured
the third aspect is availability the
best way i can make
my data confidential and trustworthy is
i can lock it up in a safe take it to
the ocean and drop it in at the bottom
of the ocean so that nobody can access
it
but that data has no value when it
cannot be accessed by anyone or any
authorized person when they require it
so for that data to be valuable for me i
need to have access to that data
whenever i require it we are basically
juggling along this triangle
where we want to keep the security in
such a way that the data is confidential
it's trustworthy and at the same time
that it is highly available to all the
authorized users
we always have been taking the example
of onedrive has it ever happened that
onedrive was not available over the
internet at any point in time
maybe a couple of times in the past few
years but 99
of the time it's always available so
they ensure that the data center that
they have created is redundant in such a
way that no matter what happens
the data on your onedrive software and
the service that they are providing will
always be made available to you
so here your business continuity
planning disaster recovery planning
change management service management
would come into the picture
where you're going to create a robust
plan of how these things are going to
work together
and make that infrastructure available
at all points in time
now let's move on to our next topic and
that is about tackling cyber crime
if you remember a few slides back we
talked about information security
information security could be about
anything normally contained within the
organization
the data that the organization has and
us securing this data by introducing the
security controls
that we talked about cyber security
would be something that is on the
internet or on the web
any web applications that i have
deployed on the internet any database
that i have that would talk about cyber
security
so if your facebook account gets hacked
or your one drive gets hacked
that's why the cyber security comes into
picture but if your physical computer
gets hacked because your password got
cracked by a physical attack
that's where your information security
is so some of the basic ways of
preventing cyber attacks on us
first and foremost use unique and strong
passwords
we have just discussed the complexity of
the passwords we want to keep them
random
they should not be guessable they should
not be based on dictionary words and
they should be randomized in such a way
that they cannot be predicted or guessed
the length of the password should be
very good
the bare minimum should be 8 characters
even that is not suggested in today's
world
it has to be at least 12 to 16
characters
an operating system in today's world
will support up to 24 or 26 characters
if you go into encryption software they
support up to 60 odd characters of
passwords
so you want to keep those unique you
want to recycle those passwords on a
regular basis
you do not want to reuse old passwords
again and again
the second measure is avoid public wi-fi
we always look for free wi-fi we go to
coffee shops because they advertise free
wi-fi
that's nowadays a unique selling point
for coffee shops and establishments
we go there connect to the wi-fi and
serve whatever we want
the problem is you have no idea who else
is connected to that wi-fi and what kind
of attacks they are creating
so public wi-fi's are very risky and if
your security is not up to the mark
you might just end up getting hacked
like nobody's business
the third measure is ignore and delete
mails from unknown senders
phishing attacks are very common attacks
in today's world
you get an email saying you have won a
lottery or you've been chosen for
something or please click here to
download your free software
such emails are plenty nowadays always
ask the question if you won a lottery
did you purchase the ticket
no so there's never a free lunch right
always keep on questioning the things
that you have been getting
i'm not saying ignore them because some
of them may actually come true
there's always at one percent hope but
always investigate those things to see
whether they have spam or there is a
fraud going on
and if yes you can communicate with the
law enforcement agency and try to figure
out who's responsible for that fraud
the fourth measure make use of antivirus
software
and always keep it updated do not go for
free antivirus softwares because they
may be good at detecting infections
but when it comes to disinfecting those
files then
that's where they ask for money that's
when you're going to run around
and say okay let me see which is a very
good antivirus to disinfect this kind of
infection
there are a lot of antiviruses out there
and i know it that it's very confusing
which is the best one today
the problem is whichever is the best one
in the market may not be the best one
for the operating system that you are
using
for example there would be a good
antivirus for windows 7
but the same antivirus installed on
windows 8 or windows 10
wouldn't be that effective the best way
to look at antiviruses and identify
which antivirus suits you is to
investigate that antivirus and see the
detection rate of that antivirus
what you can do is you can head on to
our website called virustotal.com
it's a google owned website they have
around 60 to 70 odd scanners on that
website and have most of the known
antivirus scanners
try to figure out if you can get hold of
an infected file be very careful
you don't want to infect your computer
you can upload it to that particular
website
analyze the file and see which antivirus
detects those kind of viruses
the fifth measure use multi-factor
authentication or a two-step process for
authentication
don't just rely on a username and
password registered devices get otp
either on your email or on your devices
that gives you an added layer of
security if your password gets
compromised that's still okay because
now the hacker will need to stimulate
your phone as well
there are so many other people who don't
use these kind of techniques they can be
hacked
much easier than people who have an
added layer of security introduced
and finally be very careful when you're
downloading apps
on your mobile phones you still have a
certain level of security where you can
go to the apple marketplace or the
google play store
and they do have some level of control
but when you talk about windows
operating systems you're going to open
the internet to look for different kinds
of software
you have no idea whether the website
that you're on is trustworthy or is
hosted by a hacker with a malware on
that particular file that you're
downloading
especially if you're downloading a
pirated program never download a pirated
program
when you're downloading an executable
file you can upload it to virustotal.exe
scan
it to see if there are any viruses or
malware within it
the website also helps you analyze urls
to see if the url itself may have any
malicious attacks within them
so you can use that website to scan the
apps that you're downloading and see if
there's anything malicious about
those apps so that was all about our
cyber security training for this session
before wrapping up this session i'd like
to address a few questions from you
viewers
i can see that we have a few repeatedly
asked questions from our viewers
let me address a couple of those
questions
the first question that i'm taking up is
i want to start a career in cyber
security what steps should i take
well there is no one genuine path to
working in cyber security
you should have a bachelor's degree in
any relevant field and have a deep
abiding interest to know how cyber
security works
you must also possess a relevant job
experience preferably in the field of
i.t
you should have knowledge of network
configuration tcp
network protocols firewalls vpns and
operating systems
apart from these you need to know the
secure coding practices
threat modeling virtualization
technologies
encryption technologies date and
database management systems
after you're well versed with these
skills go for a few certifications that
can push your career one step further
depending on your interest i would
suggest you look for certifications like
ch conscious security plus cism to name
a few
once you have the desired knowledge and
experience you can become a security
analyst a cyber security engineer a
security consultant or a cyber security
architect
so i hope i have answered your question
the next question i would like to take
up is
what coding language should i know to
learn cyber security
so yes you might be wondering if coding
is really required to become a cyber
security professional
well it is true that not all cyber
security professionals have or need
coding skills
however having zero coding knowledge may
limit your opportunities in the future
knowing a couple of programming
languages will help you identify
the plan behind an attack and defend
against deadly hacking techniques
c and c plus will be really helpful the
c
programming language is the backbone of
most operating systems
c and c plus plus are low-level
programming languages that you need to
know as a cyber security professional
on the other hand python is a high-level
programming language that is becoming
popular
among cyber experts today knowing python
will give you an upper hand in your
career
it will help you identify and fix
vulnerabilities
and a final pick is html html is another
language cyber security professionals
should understand
as most websites use it and it is one of
the easiest languages to learn
repeat so i hope i've addressed your
question on coding languages for
cybersecurity
if you have any more questions please
put them in the chat section below and
we'll be happy to answer them
and with that we have reached the end of
this session by simplylon on
cybersecurity training for beginners
i hope you guys found this informative
and helpful thank you for watching stay
safe and keep learning
you